bootleg cat podcast man we got a special
guest in here repping St Louis J baby
the Grady yes sir welcome yes sir what's
going on baby oh man it's good to have
you here uh samino was talking about you
last time he was here that's my bro my
brother
um shout out to my guy Anwar who reached
out and put me onto your [ __ ] my brother
yeah man
um for people who don't know who you are
man give us like a rundown of what you
got going on and and uh yeah we know you
from St Louis yeah from the career St
Louis Missouri you know what I'm saying
St Louis Lou town you know Midwest how
long you been rapping
oh [ __ ] all my life since I was like
eight so you're like uh you're new to
this you're True to this [ __ ] True to
this [ __ ] my mama had me doing this she
was uh I signed a Motown that word yeah
for sure for sure so oh I've been doing
this [ __ ] forever shout out to your moms
what's your mom was your mom like [ __ ]
Penelope Jones shout out my mama shout
out Mama shout out to Mama baby
um so
you kind of have like a cool situation
because you work with Anwar over at
carrots right but then you also have a
situation with me with smino who's from
your hometown
um who's got one of my favorite albums
of the Year by the way shout out to Sam
you know he delivered with that out go
get it now love for rent we all love
everywhere crazy love is forever tour
coming out you know yeah
um so uh how long has like how long have
you been involved with those situations
went to high school together so you guys
are you guys are like OG homies they
beat me for best forever in high school
you know what I'm saying wow yeah we had
it in right after that I had them battle
we had to battle and I do a battle after
that you know what I'm saying we battled
and then you know sometimes when you
realize somebody is good you know what
I'm saying you [ __ ] with them we just
became super that's what I'm saying
super cool so you guys went from
battling each other being like man look
we both Jedis let's just link it wasn't
even I just wanted to battle him because
he beat me in the best rap like I always
knew he was tight you know what I'm
saying in school because it was like
everybody wrapped at school right but he
was he was he was dope you know what I'm
saying and then he beat me for best rap
I'm like no I can't let you do that
because I was supposed to be the best
rapper you know back then you had a
matter for us so we just battled in the
jams who won the battle in the gym uh uh
we we got off on each we went back it
was close I like to say I won he like to
say he wants one of those things you
know of course bro nobody really won
though for real yeah but we just both
got off he got off I got off and you
guys both winning together now all these
years later I was actually at work uh
working I was working a job randomly you
know what I'm saying in between [ __ ] and
I uh was a co-worker was listening to an
album man I'm like yeah who's that he's
like dude ain't me no like smino I mean
look at his album it was bro you're like
I went to high school with him I went to
[ __ ] high school here I'm like yeah I
went to school with him like nah bro he
from Chicago I'm like no no St Louis you
know what I'm saying with the school bro
you know he beat me for best rap at the
same time they put out an interview
somebody had an interview for him and in
the interview they was talking about
that situation randomly wow and brung me
up type [ __ ] I dropped the song a couple
weeks later and the rest of the history
bro hit me up and he hit you like this
work man that [ __ ] been UPS ever since
thank bro super grateful uh I know you
uh you just put out a body of work
recently talk about what music you got
out
uh I got like
we're gonna eight right now I got eight
like EPS out yeah um white yellow orange
and it's all with the the um karate belt
Spectrum you know I'm saying I'm just
trying to go with the whole you know
karate belt thing leveling up white belt
yeah you got the is this called was this
called a ghee it's a ghee yeah you got
the carrots ski yeah he's just my first
looks like a one of one yeah hyper flag
you know what I'm saying hyperfly we
doing this we doing soon it's a
one-to-one right now but yeah these
these don't come out these will be out
next year for sure what what inspires
the karate aspect are you like in the
martial arts obviously Bruce Lee I'm
just on some Bruce Lee Vibes like you
know I just want to whoop all these
[ __ ] ass with this music [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying do you ever actually do
martial arts yeah I'm doing I'm actually
only a white belt right now you know
because I have little time to do it as
much as I want to do it you got to start
somewhere you know what I'm saying but
you got to start somewhere yeah so yeah
I got a glass and everything got a
Sensei [ __ ] what's the best Bruce Lee
movie
into the dragon yeah into the dragon
that's why I based my first EP off of
The Last Dragon go get it I'm saying
that's what I dropped with smino and you
know zero fatigue yeah those Bruce Lee
movies I remember I used to have like
the VHS box set of like just ran I think
there was one called the Chinese
connection the Chinese connection yeah
what was the Enter the Dragon the one
that had cream Abdul-Jabbar in it uh
that's uh or is that Return of the
Dragon or the last dragon or no I want
to say that's the fury one that's uh
Fist of Fury I think I want to say this
I could be wrong though I'm almost
certain yeah you would know I mean you
got all the [ __ ] karate projects
popping I could definitely be wrong yeah
you could be uh well look man
um go run I mean you got a ton of Music
out people can go look it up
um merch is a merch out yeah merch is
out I just dropped some merch with my
man sang Brown build with single you
know what I'm saying nice yeah so I got
I did certain books for certain people I
did the real one with trapaholics you
know uh did you guys did you do one with
LRG I did a couple with LRG I did uh the
first three was with LRG shout out shout
out to LG they sponsor the the freestyle
series that's family that's family I did
the first actual forward LG there's a
good guys man have you know my guy Kevin
over there yeah Kevin's a good guy with
Lily just gonna say shout out Kim I just
seen him in conference yeah he was over
there they got they had a tree house
popping hey hey shout out to capture
allergy is like back I know we super bad
they they definitely bad and you know
what they just sent me a whole load of
clothes too so shout out down for
forever yeah the closer came back man
shout out to LRG man uh hey let's get to
the raps though man and and I like your
beat let's do it selection let's do it
yeah it's a uh actually so it's a it's a
freestyle I'm about to put out soon so
I'm gonna let the world here all right
let's get it man put them headphones on
let's get to it man St Louis in the
building
jay baby the Grady let's do it let's get
it I just hit two [ __ ] at the same
time [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] monster
ain't I young [ __ ] I got some young
[ __ ] that gun [ __ ] and bomb [ __ ] get a
young dumb [ __ ] that dumb dumb dumb [ __ ]
um a dumb [ __ ] open the monster okay
they like to drum [ __ ] uh trying to get
some money get some paper oh hit the
little [ __ ] sit the paper oh got the
flick get raging uh me and seven [ __ ]
sister eight way uh walking with the
bands like it's Mayday uh killing [ __ ]
what's happening [ __ ] doing all that
rapping ain't even Boston Captain I got
more voices in average oh JB Temptation
[ __ ] what's up with all that trapping
but I never got no Pepe um boy got loose
like Jason huh yeah uh knowing them
[ __ ] from Haiti [ __ ] just happy they
made it we don't mean yeah
online brother I'm everywhere I'm the
Grady one on Twitter I'm saying I'm
trying to get this Grady [ __ ] man Elon
Musk let me get Grady on Twitter just
Grady it's great he's got down I'm
saying or jay baby the greatest you're
gonna have to pay eight dollars a month
for that oh man that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
funny as hell too young that's cool but
anyway uh on Twitter uh you know jay
baby the great one or the Grady one you
know what I'm saying uh Instagram I'm
Jay babygrady everywhere else from J
baby Grady tap in with me you know what
I'm saying [ __ ] with the kid stream it
jay baby the Grady you know what I'm
saying brown belt white belt every color
shout out Sango we out right now you're
saying if anyone is gonna go listen to
one though go to anyone go to red belt
I'm gonna go to red belt go to red belt
right now 22 tracks on there you know if
you want to really you want to get a
quick dose of the day you want to see oh
what do you got going on red belt there
it is man appreciate you pulling up bro
shout out trapaholics too that's what I
did it shout out to them man shout out
to LRG LRG presented some tapes oh yeah
LRG yeah four tapes in a raw folk of the
game you know what I'm saying let's go
back home take it home hello just let's
do some more [ __ ] drop some [ __ ] fire
hey what up I know you just watched a
crazy freestyle and guess what we got
another one coming out next week and
another one coming out the week after
and it's all presented by our family at
LRG that's right LRG uh first of all
shout out to them because they just
dropped this fire collab with Ewing
Athletics they got the sneakers they got
the sweatsuit the T-shirt all that plus
I want to give a big shout out to them
because it is Christmas time and my
promo code at lrg's website is a serious
one you saved 30 off 30 off if you go to
L Dash R
g.com and use the promo code bootleg
you'll save 30 off whatever the [ __ ] you
want on lrg's website so it's Christmas
time maybe you need some new gear maybe
you need a new jacket maybe you need a
new [ __ ] sweatsuit whatever it is
l-r-g.com we appreciate them for holding
us down use that promo code bootleg safe
30 off and we'll see you next week with
another freestyle presented by LRG